in this video we're going to talk about
how to burn fat a very important topic
but a big problem simply because pretty
much all the mainstream recommendations
for burning fat are completely outdated
in fact look at the statistics in
America only 2% of the population ever
is successfully successful at burning
fat in achieving their weight-loss goals
an average female spent 17 years dieting
so what does that tell you they're
operating off of incorrect information
what I'm going to tell you is based on
fact physiology books how the body works
there's two main fuel sources in the
body okay you have fat and you have
stored sugar there is a third one called
muscle but I'm not going to get into
that because you have to be very very
sick for your body to start using muscle
protein as a fuel source we're going to
talk about the two main ones which is
fat and sugar in other words your body
can store sugar the name of that's
called glycogen in your liver and your
muscles and that can released in between
times where you're not eating okay or it
can go after the fat so the way it works
our fat burning hormones based on what
you eat and what you do trigger the fat
and then to release certain enzymes to
dissolve that fat called lipase enzymes
their hormone sensitive fat enzymes that
break things down into ketones ketones
are the byproduct of fat metabolism and
your body can run on these very
efficiently way better actually it's a
better fuel source it's cleaner fuel
source your body can run on this even
your brain can run on ketones now fat
making hormones trigger the storage of
sugar and the conversion of the sugar
into fat so that's how that works
the great majority of people are only
burning sugar which is glucose they're
not burning
at what occurs is they will lose some
temporary water weight and they hit a
plateau thinking that's actual fat but
if they never actually burn fat and I
can prove that because I have a machine
that measures how much fact someone
burns and you can very easily see they
lose water weight and then they plateau
so great majority people burn sugar
they're not actually burning fat so in
this next section I'm going to tell you
about the single control factor what
determines whether you're burning fat or
whether you're born it burning sugar so
here it is the number one controller of
whether you burn actual fat or whether
you're burning sugar is this one hormone
called insulin
so insulin even in small amounts has the
strength in the domination to prevent
you from tapping into your fat reserve
so here's a little graph on how much
insulin or let's just say when I talk
about insulin I'm going to talk about
sugar because sugar triggers insulin so
I could easily say the number one
control of whether you burn fat is sugar
or hidden sugars but I'm just going to
call insulin sugar right now so that
sugar is high let's say it's high sugar
right here Oh high insulin you're not
going to be able to burn fat your body
is running on sugar so let's say you eat
moderately and you have let's say half
of them on a sugar so because someone
said everything in moderation you know
it still won't work because insulin has
to be zero or sugar has to be zero to
tap into ketones which are is the
byproduct of fat burning which is
ketosis so in other words it's not a
graph that's a gradual graph you have to
make insulin or so we say sugar zero
before you can burn fat so now we're
going to talk about is this thing called
ketosis ketosis is what we want to get
into and you may hear some negative
things about ketosis because it relates
to diabetes but we're talking about
doing ketosis in a very healthy way okay
ketosis is the healthiest thing to do
for your blood sugars for your heart for
your brain and other conditions like
polycystic ovarian syndrome really
really important because think about
that condition persons usually always
insulin resistant and if they put if
they if they go on this they see great
improvements okay so we want to get the
person in ketosis to get in ketosis
usually does not happen overnight it's
easy to tap into the sugar reserve
because all you have to do is eat sugar
but to get into ketosis it can sometimes
take way more than two days it could
take a week to two weeks up to a month
and maybe in some situations five or
even six weeks before you're really
hardcore into fat burning now why is
that because you've been living on sugar
your whole life and your system is so
inefficient and so used to burning sugar
to convert that over it's called a keto
adaptation so you're adapting to burning
fat just takes a little bit longer don't
worry about it because you can see
ketones in your urine within a few days
but the point is you want to stick with
it a little longer and I think what
discourages a lot of people is they
think they're going to burn fat in a day
or two and they get discouraged and they
stop when in fact to adapt your body
into a fat-burning it could take up to a
month two possibly six weeks in very
extreme cases I'm telling you that
because it might happen in a week or
maybe a little longer than a week but
just hang in there and stick with it
because it will happen and your body
will be burning fat and a lot of
problems will actually go away so now
let's talk about what foods that you
have to eat to get into ketosis ok so
here's here's what you need to eat
number one you want to keep your
carbohydrates within 5 to 10 percent of
the entire amount of calories that you
eat in a given day now the type of
carbohydrates we're going to recommend
our vegetable in nature so why vegetable
even though they have a small amount of
carbohydrate they have a lot of vitamins
and minerals that you're not going to
get with protein or fat so we do want
the vegetable carbohydrates here in a
good amount okay but the net sugars from
that is going to be very very very low
if anything at all okay
25% of your diet should come in the form
of protein this thing that I'm telling
you is not the Atkins diet Atkins is a
lot of protein our body is not made out
of carbohydrate some of her body is
protein but a lot of our body is made
out of fat and that's the third one
right here 65 to 80 percent of your
calories should be in the form of fat
now before you freak out realize that
I'm actually have been in ketosis for
quite a while and I have a lot of
clients that also have been in ketosis
and it's a very healthy thing to do
because you feel so good
but fat is good it's going to be in the
form of healthy fats and it's not going
to be absolutely deep-fried you know
anything so we want the carbohydrates
vegetable we want the protein so that
would kind of come out to about let's
say about four to five maybe six ounces
of protein with each meal okay but see
most protein comes with fat so a lot of
your protein source actually comes from
fat as well but you do not want to
consume the lean proteins and that is
because you need that fat to get your
body into ketosis Eskimos consume
blubber and they actually are in a state
of ketosis and they can actually a lot
of them actually have zero heart
problems at all and if you're concerned
about increasing your cholesterol
realize this your body makes 2,000
milligrams of cholesterol every single
day why would your body make that much
cholesterol if it didn't need it so when
you consume more cholesterol or fat your
body just makes less that's how it work
you need this cholesterol to build the
surrounding around on your cells you
need is raw material to build up your
hormones especially stress hormone so
you need it for the lens of the eye and
even the brain a lot of cholesterol is
in our brain to help the nerve a
connectivity so your body adapts to that
so we need a lot of it I mean like one
egg would be 300 milligrams so you have
to have like 40 eggs to equal what your
body makes every single day but it
adapts so you eat less your body makes
more you eat more the body makes less so
now 65 to 80 percent of your body should
be in the form of fat so that is the
formula to get someone in fat burning
one time in high school I tried to I - I
was a wrestler and I tried to gain
weight and so when I did is I decided
well of course if I wanna gain weight I
have to eat fatty foods I started losing
weight the more fat that I ate and that
kind of confused me until later when I
got into the physiology of it I found
out that consuming fat is neutral with
insulin eating fat does not trigger
insulin insulin is the key thing that
must be zero because once you get your
body into fat-burning by doing this all
it's going to take is a little bit of
sugar to totally throw you out of
ketosis once your body is adapt to it
but you'll feel much better with your
energy with your cardiovascular with
your endurance and if you add exercise
on top of this oh my gosh it's going to
be huge a lot of professional athletes
are going into this as well because they
have a lot better performance and a lot
of credible medical doctors are even
recommending this as well so it's a it's
a new thing and you know it's true
because it's the exact opposite of what
mainstream is telling you to do they're
saying have 60% of your diet
carbohydrates and have only 5 to 10
percent fat and protein the same so you
know it's correct so if you just did the
opposite of what everyone tells you to
do you'll come out of
now if you want to know the specifics of
what exact types of fats that you should
have and what combinations and some
ideas of maybe some snacks click the
link below and you can download a page
of what to eat and how to do this
correctly all right so I hope you enjoy
this and I will see you in the next
video